martine maldonado will be catching zach
grenke today veteran right-hander on the
season is 11-6 has a 3-9-4 era this will
be his second start since coming off the
injured list
and then he dots him up right at the
bottom of the zone rojas may have had an
argument on the 3-1 pitch but that 3-2
pitch was right there diamond back six
to four winners yesterday the one-two
strike three call on the outside corner
and marty not happy don't blame him laz
diaz early on has shown he's gonna call
a few inches off that outside corner to
left-handed hitters and if so grinky
could have a field day grinky's pitch
curve ball and that's lifted in the left
field coming in mccormick and he makes
the catch to retire the side so an easy
breezy one two three inning for grinky
and after a half inning of play
diamondbacks nothing astros coming up
record this season not very good two and
ten four four four era and that whip
almost a one and a half he has 118
strikeouts on the season and is allowed
15 home runs here's a 1-2 pitch and a
swinging strike three gallons strikes
out diaz and one out of the inning now
he faces bregman
on the ground towards the hole into left
field in between third and short alex
bregman didn't hit it hard but he found
the right find down the right spot on
the left side of the infield for a base
hit now to be at second bregman at first
no score bottom of the first the batter
is jordan alvarez runners aren't going
the pitch and a swing and a miss another
good change up got him swinging second
strikeout for gallon and now two outs in
the inning and there are two out but
still two men on for correa the kick and
the pitch
and that's driven pretty deep to right
back is smith still going back at the
wall see you later
a three-run home run for carlos correa
and the astros have jumped out to a
three-nothing lead matches his career
high with his 24th home run of the year
mccormick we're sitting 250 on the air
with 12 home runs 47 rbis
and a swinging strike three so galla
records his third strikeout and that's
the first stop here in the second inning
called strike three fast ball away las
diaz got a pretty chunky strike zone
today and gallon takes advantage there
is four strikeout smith comes in hitting
266. 10 overs 46 runs batted in he's
only two for 15 on the road trip haven
smith turns on one and drives it way out
of here paving smith
launches one against zach cranky and
gets the d-backs on the board and it's a
3-1 ball game first diamondback hit they
get a run with it smith's 11th of the
year
that's a grounder and it's stabbed by
grinky to his left
jog's halfway to first underhands
and he completes it and it's a one to
three put out
and that'll do it for the diamondbacks
here in the third inning we'll go to the
bottom of the third it's the astros
three diamondbacks one chance for a
shutdown in here for gallon and altuve
into right hits it pretty well smith
back at the wall he's got it front of
the wall out there made a nice catch on
the warning track gets some applause
from zach gallon on a nice running catch
out there one out the pitch line to left
center field that's a base hit cutting
it off as peralta it's a sharp single by
diaz with one out got the change up
gallon left it up
the 2-1
pitch and a high drive
hit to deep center field
smith back he's got room he's got it and
that will retire the side hit to the
deepest part of the ballpark two out of
the inning with one man out and that'll
bring up carson kelly now frankie to
kelly
got a shot to right center that's going
to drop for a hit brother around third
he'll come around to score you know the
throw in is not in time and now it's a
one-run ball game the rbi for carson
kelly now the dive diamondbacks have
calhoun at second kelly at first with
one out for varshall this guy he wanted
to play right now there's a ground ball
and that's by altuve into right center
of base set turning third coming to the
plate calhoun now the throw to third not
in time kelly got in there rbi single
var show and this game is tied at three
so singleton third a tie ball game now
the diamondbacks a chance to get the
lead walker sends one out to right
center that gets one home carson is
scored varshall coming around third and
he will score walkers knocked in two and
it's five three diamondbacks
the astros trying to answer the
diamondbacks after their four in the top
of the fourth
there's a ball in the right center field
that is down and all the way towards the
wall cut off by the center fielder
varshall correa will score tucker and
rbi double astros now down by one it's
five to four what a good piece of
hitting kyle tucker
it's a ground ball to the left side
shortstop rojas has it slings it low and
it gets by the first baseman tucker over
to third base on the error by rojas and
a break for the astros
first one is hit on the ground down to
third they go to singapore one there
comes the throw to the plate and they
have tucker caught in the run down he's
tagged out so a nice play there van
meter through to sing it marty was alert
fired to the plate as tiger had started
the plate ends into a double play
boy that was all marty there
breaking ball a little tapper gallon
has it underhands the first for the out
to get maldonado and that'll end the
ending well the astros gotta run it
could have been worse for the d-backs
they'll keep the lead they'll bring up
calhoun who now will not be facing
grinky
and a shot into left center field and
that ball is caught by myers the tag at
third by rojas he'll come in to score
and back to second hustles marte sac fly
by calhoun but a really nice play by
myers robbing calhoun of a hit gallon
back to work of the six fifth inning a
one two three go of it
called strike three
gallon got that grinky call and it was a
strike for zach ranky throughout the
entire inning earlier in the ball game
and now that goes in gallons column
here's gallant's pitch
strike three got him now korea's going
to bark just a little bit he's back to
the time got back-to-back case in the
inning for gallon who now has struck out
six in the ball game and he delivers to
siri got him swinging and he strikes out
the side one two three go the astros and
the six we go to the seven six four d
backs and it's the major league debut
for the 23 year old right-hander luis
frias back-to-back walks allowed by luis
frias and now the astros in business
with jose altuve do up
he got him swinging came back with the
same pitch and now two based down on
strikes that's his first big league
strikeout bases are filled with astros
and alex bregman due up the 1-1 pitch to
bregman is on the way and a shot to
center
marshall coming on and he's got it to
retire the side hit it hard but out
correa is at first with one out in the
inning series struck out swinging in the
sixth inning
and that is hammer deep to left field
looking up peralta see you later we're
tied
jose series third big league home run is
on to the train tracks six six ball game
how about the bat flip after he hit that
my goodness mccormick go for three he's
reached on an error
and mccormick drives this one deep to
left center field peralta is going back
looking up see you later
back-to-back jacks and the astros lead
first series now mccormick it's 7-6 ryan
presley will be on here in the ninth
inning in a potential save situation he
has 24 on the season
swaying and a miss
got him with a breaking ball strikeout
to start the ninth inning one away
call third strike ryan presley drops in
the hook for a call third back-to-back
strikeouts two away in the ninth got him
strikes out the side ryan presley ends
it
striking out josh van meter the astros
take this series winning two out of
three